statement it says after everything
that's happened it's still unbelievably
painful to know that the prime minister
was partying and breaking his own
lockdown rules while we were unable to
be at our loved ones sides in their
dying moments or in miserable funerals
with only a handful of people because we
were following the rules
the fact that the prime minister and his
chancellor then lied about it and would
have continued to do so if the police
had not intervened is truly shameless
they broke the law but even worse they
took us all for mugs
when we met the pm in the number 10
garden the same one where they had these
parties he looked us in the eye and said
he had done everything he could to save
our loved ones we now know that was a
lie there is simply no way either the
prime minister or chancellor can
continue their dishonesty has caused
untold hurt to the bereaved not only
that but they've lost all credibility
with the wider public which could cost
lives if new variants mean restrictions
are needed in the future if they had any
decency they would be gone by tonight
not from the bereaved families and just
to let you know i'm going to be speaking
to lobby canola a member of that
bereaved families group whose father
died during the first weeks of the covet
pandemic in about an hour's time
well now to ukraine and pro-russian
forces have denied using chemical
weapons in the besieged city of mariupol
western nations are urgently working to
try to verify the reports but if proven
true britain's armed forces minister
james heapey says all options are on the
table as to how allies respond
meanwhile vladimir putin has said russia
will press on with its military
operation in ukraine until its goals are
fulfilled the russian president said the
military action was going according to
plan and wasn't moving faster because
russia he said wanted to minimize losses
well let's get to your questions on
ukraine straight away our security and
defense analyst professor michael clark
is here as ever very good evening again
to you michael let's uh dive straight in
and
start with aaron who asked us about the
possibility of chemical weapons being
used in ukraine specifically in the
south of the country uh which we've just
been reporting on and aaron just asked
this michael how will the west respond
if it is confirmed that putin's military
used chemical weapons in mariu paul as
james sepia
said there said well all options are on
the table that presumably means military
action as well
in theory it could be i james heapey
this morning i heard that interview and
he sounded a bit careful with his words
but he didn't want to
express the idea that we weren't going
to take it very seriously because if
this threshold has been crossed it's a
very big threshold indeed because
chemical weapons are weapons of mass
destruction now i have to say
immediately the evidence for this
particular chemical attack isn't great
at the moment it it looks is if it
happened it looks as if it was a rather
small attack it might have been a a
something dropped from a drone it looks
as if maybe three people have been
injured very hard to check up on unless
you can get soil samples and uh examine
the people who've been affected by it
but
chemicals come in all shapes and sizes
so there may be nerve agents like sarin
or vx there may be blistering agents
like mustard gas there may be um choking
agents like chlorine or fosgene which if
this was anything my guess would be it
might have been chlorine
um very hard to check up on and we
should be very careful because president
zlensky stopped short of saying this is
a chemical attack he knows if he accuses
the russians of doing it and we can't
prove it that his credibility will be
damaged so he's been very careful and
the final point is that this
this accusation came from the azov uh uh
battalion who are fighting in uh in
mario paul they are the you know ultra
right-wing
people they're good fighters but they're
strange and they are neo-nazis if they
actually said it i'd be
i'd be a little bit careful
in taking their word for it because
they've got their own agendas in all of
this and of course there's a difficulty
of investigating it all in absolutely
also another question on this is from
aaron a pressing question of course
about a response to the use of chemical
weapons so following down the same
thread should nato commit to
implementing a no-fly zone over ukraine
if russia is found guilty of using
chemical weapons on civilians well this
is exploring what what options that that
are on the table off discussed could
this trigger yeah i've always thought it
wouldn't um because a no-fly zone is a
very big step there are other things we
could do before that um but a no-fly
zone remember isn't just a question of
challenging russian aircraft in the sky
to implement a no-fly zone you've
actually would have to attack
ground-based radars and ground-based
anti-aircraft systems or you're going to
get shot out of the sky yourselves and
remember a no-fly zone won't do anything
about helicopters which fly low it won't
do anything really about cruise missiles
russian cruise missiles nor will it do
anything about what's causing most
damage which is good old-fashioned field
artillery from the 1980s so no-fly zone
is it sounds easy
but a you couldn't implement it without
getting into real uh war with russian
forces and b it wouldn't make a whole
lot of difference to what is actually
going on on the ground but but i think
that the if if the chemical threshold
has been crossed then i think what the
west will do is more of the same so
sanctions yeah so so we i mean i think
we might throw all of the russian banks
out of the swift system instead of i
think it's only three of the big five
are still in the system we might
actually then go for really big cuts in
russian energy even though it would hurt
it would hurt us to do that but we might
we're moving towards it and we might go
for secondary sanctions which is to say
we will sanction any company dealing
with a russian company that we sanction
which would mean in reality sanctioning
lots of chinese companies again it would
hurt us but it would be a very big move
so with the things that the west is
doing now
if we are prepared to take the pain if
we are so outraged we could ratchet them
all up quite a lot and i'm fairly sure
that that's what western leaders will do
before they will get involved in a
shooting war with russian forces that's
broadened it out uh through paul's
two-part question in actual fact he's uh
asking this is it possible for ukraine
to beat russia or will russia prevail
and what is putin's end game now uh
within that question i'm guessing
michael you know we have to kind of
define what beating russia would look
like just i mean it doesn't mean getting
that all together or you know kind of
yeah school draw well what the
ukrainians have done they've fought the
russians to a standstill in the north
around around kiev and chernahiv and
sumi and maybe even kharkiv they fought
them to stand still they may be able to
do that in the donbass as well we'll see
you know we might talk about that a bit
later on
and by fighting them to a standstill
they force them to change their strategy
which which opens up a new political set
of possibilities for the ukrainians and
this is where we say what is putin's
endgame i mean the short andrews i wish
we knew and i wish he knew because i
don't think he does really no he started
off this whole project which was to take
over ukraine quickly three days get it
all over by the eighth of march mopping
up operations and he would have grabbed
ukraine the rest of the world would be
outraged and they would just weather the
storm and in four or five years time it
would all be over and he would have
created the basis of this nouveau russia
the russia that looks a bit like
catherine the greatest russia that was
his legacy in history before he dies
that was his aim it was based on a huge
huge failure of intelligence
understanding what ukraine was like
these days and a great failure of his
intelligence thinking that he could
achieve it so that was his original aim
now he can't do that he's now going for
much smaller military objectives which
is grabbing the donbass it seems and a
land corridor to crimea but while his
military objectives get smaller his
political rhetoric gets bigger wild and
so he's claiming now that ukraine is not
just dominated by a nazi government
they're all nazis in ukraine and the
whole of ukraine needs to be de-nazified
that's what he's saying in other parts
of the west absolutely he's saying that
ukraine is now the is that essentially
in a place like latvia and estonia
they're nazi the germans are basically
nazi and the americans the american
imperialists are using european nazis to
destroy russia and they're doing it
through ukraine so his rhetoric has
become ridiculous chilling and the
problem is the question we're asking us
every day we read these articles i mean
the the previous ambassador to britain
wrote an article yesterday where he said
we are in the great patriotic war
version two he wrote that just yesterday
and we say to ourselves do they really
believe this
do they believe their own propaganda or
are they just saying this because they
have to have a rationale for a big war
that has gone terribly wrong so my i'll
come back to where i started i don't
think putin knows what his aims are now
he knows that he hasn't achieved his
main aim and he's he's trying to work
out some way of getting something out of
this that is his legacy in history we'll
explore more of that through this
question from adam adam says well
russia would have wanted many major
cities to fall within hours we're now
almost 50 days in as we know what went
so wrong for the kremlin well i i'm
going to ask well you know has it
actually gone
wrong for the kremlin as you say they're
readjusting their objectives and heaven
knows what's coming in the next few
weeks they've certainly lost the first
phase of the war no no doubt i mean they
lost in the north they the russians have
gone from kiev they've gone from journey
they've gone from swimming they've been
beaten no question that doesn't mean to
say they'll lose the war it rather
depends on on what happens next but but
everything went wrong from the top down
in the sense that the the mission was
impossible the the russian military
machine was very unreformed and we
thought we all knew that they had these
weaknesses like the weakness as the old
red army but we all assumed in the
military analysis community that if they
were going to invade they must have put
these things right at least for the
forces that they've got arranged around
ukraine they must have actually made an
effort to get some of these things right
but they didn't and if it comes down to
a single thing a single element i would
say it's the lack of an nco cardra the
lack of non-commissioned officers so
sergeants corporals lance corporals who
can think on their feet exactly and they
are the backbone of any army the
officers the in in the russian army the
office is a bit detached the ncos the
sergeants the corporals they're all
they're all on the fiddle um they're not
they're corrupt the men don't like them
they don't like the men and if you take
western armies the british army is very
famous i mean we are an army of ncos our
army and you know when the sergeant says
think of me as your mother
they mean it they don't mean that
they're going to come and kiss you good
night but they do me
they do mean that they'll do they'll
keep up your drills and skills it's all
about drills and skills and in a tight
situation your drills and skills will
make you good soldiers they will keep
you alive and at the end of it your
sergeant your corporal will bring you
all home and that's what the nco does
it's the backbone and they don't have it
they don't have it well let's uh focus
as i mentioned there on the next few
weeks and days a very important question
uh this one is how likely is it that
russia will win the battle for the
donbass region now that's going to be
very different to what happened around
kiev then i'm not going to get long
columns driving down a single road
through marshland easier targets yes but
they've they've done it at the wrong
time i mean i'd say it's 50 50 this
funny of the numbers are about equal the
russians have got these 10 new battalion
task groups battalion tactical groups
forming they've got their probably 30
btgs already there so they're probably
going to end up with about 40 btgs
around the donbass region which is about
30 to 35 000 troops the ukrainians in
their forces have got well started with
about the same 35 to 40 000 although
they will have reduced some of those now
it will be a different sort of battle it
will resemble a bit more the second
world war battles in a way
but the russians have left it at the
wrong time that you know the time to use
armored forces in ukraine is in the
winter when the ground is hard or in the
summer when the ground is dusty and hard
but in the spring and the autumn it's
very difficult to use armored forces so
the russians will again be stuck using
the roads not being able to fan out they
will be vulnerable and they have a
problem so they're bringing all this
stuff down from kiev and chernov
via bell garage and interestingly
yesterday somebody blew the railway line
up at belgarrod quite badly um the
russians will repair it but i suspect
that that railway line is going to get
blown up quite a lot in the coming weeks
so that they've got they've got a big
logistical issue
to perform in actually getting their
stuff as around the outside of the clock
through russia through belarus and
russia down into the south east so they
can enter the clock as it were at about
five o'clock where the the donbass is
the ukrainians um they've got very good
forces in the donbass but they don't
have a lot of mobility they've been
there since 2014 they've dug in they've
not been a maneuver force so the
russians have got their maneuver
problems the ukrainians got their
maneuver problems and they're about the
same roughly the same size though the
russians will have will have a lot more
firepower to bring in so i had to if i
had to say now
it's 50 50. it and it will come down to
the quality of of soldiering and the
quality of leadership okay yeah much
more on that coming up fascinating so
far michael uh you're watching a special
question and answer program on the war
in ukraine next we are asking if putin
is successful in eastern ukraine how can
the west credibly deal with him in the
future stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
[Applause]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark answering your questions about the
war in ukraine we've got one from rachel
now it's in regards to the nature of the
relationship between the west and putin
and whether
this is looking more like the cold war
rachel assif putin is successful in
eastern ukraine how can the west
credibly deal with him in the future is
this now the new cold war
that is the problem i mean
ultimately there has to be some kind of
negotiations then how could you ever
trust president putin after absolutely
and rachel's quite right i mean we're in
cold war two we didn't ask for it but
we're pitched into it since the 24th of
february
and the world changed on the 24th of
february just the way it changed at 9
11. uh just the way it changed when the
berlin wall came down on the 11th of
november 1989 nothing will be the same
afterwards and one of the things that
won't be the same
is that for as long as mr putin is in
power in russia then we can't trust
anything that they say or do because
he's lied and lied and lied and he's
been aggressive from 2008 to 2022 in
more or less everything he's done um in
georgia south ossetia uh abhasia um in
uh syria in uh uh now in mali and in
libya et cetera et cetera and now in
ukraine uh three times this is the third
invasion of ukraine since 2014. so
russia is a different animal we can't we
can't baby him along anymore we can't
try and coax him into accepting the sort
of europe we'd like it to be so we've
got to live in cold war too and we've
got to prevail in cold war too with mr
putin and probably whoever comes after
mr putin who isn't probably going to be
a nice person either would there be
differences in cold war ii to cold war
one in that they kind of settled into
uneasy equilibrium in cold war one both
knew there was mutually essential
destruction through nuclear weapons but
kind of then just glared at each other
but didn't take each other off but the
difference is that in cold war one the
soviet union was a big power in cold war
ii russia is a very um uh volatile
at the moment a very aggressive power
but actually rather weak power it's on
the wrong side of history i mean you
know the british gdp is about two
trillion dollars about 2.2 2.3 trillion
dollars which is about
uh 2 000 billion dollars 2 000 billion
think of it that way the russian gdp is
about 1.6
uh trillion dollars so it's only two
thirds of our size and yet they're
four times bigger than twice two and a
half times the population i mean russia
is a is a
it's not a it's not a poor state but it
is not a strong state in the way that
soviet union was and even its
relationship with china which putin
talks about all the time i mean he's
very much the the minor player in the
relationship with china so
the the issue is that russia is much
weaker than the soviet union was but is
more inclined to be uh reckless and
aggressive under his leadership so it's
more dangerous in that respect okay well
we've got a another question on
possible conflicts between nato and
russia what would happen if nato did
intervene in ukraine
does russia have the resources to fight
the combined military might of so many
countries well judging on its
performance so far in ukraine the answer
to that would be definitely no no no
again since the end of the cold war um i
mean russia is now
significantly weaker in conventional
terms than the combined armies of nato
which is now 30 nations and might soon
be 32 nations if finland and sweden join
who are militarily pretty significant
both geographically and militarily that
they really will add quite a lot to
nato's um capabilities whereas most of
the new new members have added nothing
they're small and they've been taking
him for political reasons so um no
question the in in conventional terms
the west is much much stronger than
russia which is why
russia now relies on nuclear weapons
more than it ever did before and why
president putin constantly talks about
russia's nuclear forces and that's the
answer to the first part of the question
then what would happen if nato
intervened in ukraine nuclear war he
well he would threaten it he would i
don't know how he would threaten it but
he would make it clear that we're we're
playing with fire that if you do this
you're playing with fire because it
might become nuclear and that's his
constant threat and so he is deterring
us all the time with his nuclear threat
his implied nuclear threat from taking
on the russians with conventional forces
okay we've got an overarching question
before we go to another break many are
asking this about who's really
prevailing in this conflict and it's
even though russia is bigger and has
more firepower we know that who is
really dominating this war right now i
mean what is your assessment michael
given all we've discussed so far this
evening
i i think the ukrainians are winning in
the sense that they're frustrating
everything russia has tried to do and
they're winning the information war
hands down hands down 75 75 of the
ukrainian population have got
smartphones and are connected to the
internet and that is a massive
intelligence source for the ukrainian
forces because people are seeing what
they see and they're uploading material
onto secure sites and giving ukrainians
as it were a bird's bird's-eye view of
everything that's going on or a worm's
eye view and so in that respect i'd say
the ukrainians they're winning because
they're holding off everything the
russians try
but the fact is
russia is on the point and putin's on
the point where he now has to decide
either to somehow find a way out of this
wall or to go in for national
mobilization he's always trying to avoid
that because he's saying this is a
special military operation it's not a
war don't call it a war or you go to
prison for 15 years that was his law
he's now at the point where he's called
up 60 000 reservists they've called up
the new conscript units conscripts for
this year 135 000 it still probably
won't be enough
he's this this is i think why he's
talking about this is now a war against
the nazis of europe trying to destroy
russia he's on the point of mobilizing
nationally and if he does then they can
keep feeding people and weapons in and a
very long and horrible war ahead what i
mean what credence do you give to this
theory that he wants something done and
dusted by may the ninth for this victory
parade through red square yeah it's not
just the parade it's the speeches as
well they make lots of speeches and we
all we'll look at the speeches very
carefully from year to year to see what
they uh indicate um yes british and
american intelligence who've been
writing about everything else on this
war so far say
that actually uh he does care about this
may the ninth parade and speeches and
that he wants something and i think he
wants mario paul he wants some sort of
encirclement in the donbass so he can
say we've we've got it we've we've we
have protected the russian speakers in
the donbass it won't be true but he
wants to be able to say it with some
degree of credibility at least in the
russian press okay michael for the time
being thank you very much indeed you are
watching a special question and answer
on the war in ukraine coming up next are
ukrainian soldiers running out of
ammunition
well that's i mean
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark answering your questions about the
war in ukraine and our next question is
from anissa who asks what has the war
meant for ordinary ukrainians we're
going to get on to that uh
issue of what does the zed stand for but
i want to stick with
um question we seem to have gone a
little bit wrong there with our graphic
secrets
michael that what is the war meant for
ordinary ukrainians in towns and cities
that aren't being directly bombed i mean
it's it's a massive country and
huge parts of it aren't directly
involved in the conflict that's right i
mean in geographical terms it's europe's
biggest countries biggest territory in
europe and it's 45 million people so
it's in european terms it's one of the
big five so you'd say the countries are
you know britain uh france germany italy
or the big four and you put ukraine in
that category if you include in europe
so there are five big countries in terms
of area population it's not nearly as
rich as the other big four but it's big
um and ordinary ukrainians as far as we
can tell they're getting on with their
their lives but they're very anxious of
course they are and i was listening to
some of you ukrainian agricultural um
specialists recently who are saying yeah
well the you know the winter grain is in
uh the wheat is in they can't send it
anywhere because mario paul is under is
is uh being bombed and odessa is on the
blockade so they've got a problem in
getting their wheat out but they've
harvested they're carrying on their
agriculture as normal and so for a big
country like this a lot of people are
leading if you like ordinary lives with
this shadow of the war
hanging over them and of course they're
hoping hoping that somehow
the ukrainian armed forces will throw
the russians out at least from the
territories they've taken since the 24th
of february we're hearing from the world
bank the economy obviously has crashed
and they must be dealing with millions
of displaced people refugees within the
country itself they haven't all left
ukraine no no the the refugees think
well there seems to be about 10 million
internally displaced people idps as
they're not very nicely called out of a
population of 44 45 million and of those
10 million who've had to leave their
homes for various reasons
uh about uh four four to four and a half
million are now abroad they've had to go
elsewhere in europe so about 2.3 million
are in poland and if you look at the
other countries in europe on the borders
about most of them have got 300 350 000
one of the interesting things about this
thurman is that for that number of
refugees to have gone westwards almost
all have gone west was a few have gone
to russia but not many
of those refugees there are no refugee
camps in europe normally you'd expect
refugee camps anywhere that there are
reception centers but by and large those
people have been absorbed into european
societies which is you know something to
be people glad about into people's homes
that's right yeah some of them here not
too many um our next question is from
twitter i wonder if we can get it up
there i think um our systems have oh
they haven't rushed they're back here we
are
there have been recent reports that
ukrainian soldiers are running out of
ammunition what should happen next for
ukraine to succeed well we know we hear
it every night from president zielenski
they need more ammunition they need more
armaments yeah the ukrainians need more
standard ammunition so they need more
rounds for their armored vehicles rounds
for their
small arms and so on they just need more
ammunition in the way that most soldiers
understand it and the the russians also
running out of ammunition they're
running out of precision guided
munitions they they their rate of usage
has actually dropped off because they
just don't have as many so they don't
seem to be using cruise missiles as much
they're certainly not using smart bombs
as much because within the russian
arsenal about 90 percent of all of their
weapons are dumb bombs and weapons dom
in the sense that they're not guided
whereas in the west is the other way
around 90 of our armaments are smart in
some way which is that they're guided
and they're meant to be precise only 10
are dumb so the russians are
rapidly running out of smart munitions
but both sides need more ammunition but
they need different sorts of ammunition
having said that the ukrainians seem to
be getting ammunition quite freely as
far as we can tell but in mario paul the
marines were tweeting this morning
they're saying we're out of ammunition
some said no no they're not the but but
there's a there's a very um
there's a tweet which really impressed
me this morning one of the marines said
we're out of ammunition now that's it
and he said you know when you think of
the marines in mario paul think of us
kindly he said we've done everything
that's possible and quite a lot that's
impossible and just what about rush and
i mean at the very beginning of the
conflict we were awfully worried weren't
we about china supplying them with
weapons that's all gone very quiet could
that be happening surreptitiously yeah
the well the russians asked them for
weapons mainly for we think for
high-tech stuff for the precision
munitions that they were running out of
the chinese were a bit non-committal
they seem to have provided some
non-lethal or low-level supplies but
there's no indication yet that they're
supplying them with what the russians
really need and you can you can take it
from me that western intelligence
agencies are watching very very
carefully so if chinese munitions turn
up on the battlefield we will know so
far i'm not aware that they have in any
significant numbers but if they do it
will be an international issue and the
west and and the americans will
certainly be taking it up with xi
jinping one other thing to say about all
that
chinese trade with russia is about 160
billion dollars a year chinese trade
with america is 600 billion a year and
chinese trade with europe is 800 billion
dollars a year so as people are saying
look we shouldn't be frightened of china
on this you know they need us
economically a lot more than they need
russia okay we've got an anonymous
question here in in part about that uh
huge grain harvest you were talking
about there michael what are the
knock-on effects for the rest of the
world regarding food resources and
refugees if putin succeeds
and destroys what we now know as ukraine
are we prepared for that and we're
hearing you know when it comes to
food the knock-on effects are global
short-term issues for food are very
serious because this uh ukraine is the
biggest um wheat exporter in the world
it's just grain of all sorts of russia
and ukraine between them do a lot of
great but but ukraine is the biggest
exporter of wheat which is of course
basis of bread and most of that
stuff goes either to china
or to the middle east and africa and in
particular in the middle east and africa
there's already a food crisis for
environmental reasons this is the the
fact that the ukrainians can't get their
their harvest away is causing even more
acute distress elsewhere in the world so
the short-term issue and it's not just
on on
on agriculture but it's also on
manufactured goods as well because
ukraine was a pretty big manufacturer of
quite heavy goods so the short-term
effect is yes it's affecting the rest of
the world the long-term effect is the
the the question of you know if ukraine
disappears in the way we've known it the
long-term effect is that this is yet
another change in a border through force
you know no borders have changed through
four since 1945 until the russians
changed them in 2014 and have changed
them again in 2020 so only russia has
changed borders by force since the end
of the second world war and that drives
a coaching horses through international
law and the rules-based system and
within the question also the putin's
ambition again for ukraine destroys what
we now know as ukraine presumably
initially the plan was to absorb it as
you say into greater russia
is it now or could it be just destroy it
break it hobble it that's what they say
i mean that's what that's what russian
commentators are now saying they're
saying that the denatification of
ukraine will involve the
de-ukrainianization of ukraine and
that's the phrase they use in russian
denaturation and
de-ukrainianization so they've got to
erase this that's why people are now
talking terms of genocide because
they're trying to erase ukrainian um
nationality ukrainian nationhood as a as
a phenomenon in world politics i mean i
don't think they can even begin to do it
but these are the terms in which they're
now talking because the rhetoric in this
last six weeks has gone sky high
compared even to the rather inflamed
rhetoric we had before the 24th of
february okay got a question now about
some of those millions upon millions of
refugees and this shocking statistic the
u.n says is from david 4.8 million
ukrainian children have been displaced
since the invasion why didn't the
international community
act sooner well i suppose in part
because they didn't think this would
happen
it was the failure of deterrence in a
way the international community saw this
was happening back in october last year
started that is the british and american
i should really say american and british
intelligence they led on it
could see it was happening they briefed
it to the ukrainians in october
ukrainians didn't believe it because
they didn't want to believe it
and one or two other um intelligence
organizations didn't believe it and
briefed against the british and the
americans
and so there was a kind of briefing war
going on in ukraine
from december onwards about whether it
was really true or not and so
um by as it were
announcing everything that we thought
the russians were going to do and people
sort of rolled their eyes at the time
there was a tip an attempt to deter the
russians to say look we know what you're
up to don't try it we can all see what's
going to happen but of course it failed
um the russians you know lied and lied
and lied and then did it anyway and so
you know there was a reasonable attempt
to head this off
by showing that we knew what was
happening
but nobody was ever going to attack
russia to stop russia attacking ukraine
and so this tragedy
i'm sad to say
i can't see how it could have worked out
any other way from the west's point of
view a lot of lessons to be learned
though a question has been asked about
the tell this may take on relationships
between the peoples in these countries
close countries of course so what was
the relationship like between russians
and ukrainians before the conflict has
it changed now well i can answer that
one that's for sure because i mean you
know putin is killing russians yeah in
mariupol he's done it before in chechnya
he's done it in georgia he's prepared to
do that yeah and in the in the cities
that the russians have tried to um
capture and fail to capture i mean
half of the uh citizens were russian
speakers and most of them two thirds or
three quarters even were russian
speakers and up to half were russian
nationals only ethnic russians and so
putin assumed that these people would
just welcome the russians in and it
couldn't have been more wrong and the
more the war has gone on the more
ukrainian all these people have really
become and of course it's changed the
the whole dynamic there's lots of
anecdotal evidence it's only anecdotal
but i mean the number of stories we now
hear of people who say i ring my
relatives in moscow and i can't talk to
them anymore because they tell me that
we're all nazis and we're being
manipulated by the americans and i tell
them don't you understand what's going
on don't be ridiculous you know these
are all sort of stories made up by the
kiev government there's a complete
failure to be able to engage between
family members who are russian and
ukrainian
so a very difficult relationship in the
future however it pans out so we are
going to take a break here and you're
watching a special question and answer
program on the war in ukraine next we'll
be asking will we ever know for sure how
many russian soldiers have actually died
during the course of this war
[Music]
i'm nigerian uh my family here from
lagos um and like most other people from
across the continent
i've grown up realizing that people
don't really necessarily respect our
individual identities um if you speak to
people from
you know from nigeria to ghana south
africa they'll tell you that throughout
the world they are lumped um as being
african um and if you ask most people
what it means to be african um two
particular images will come to mind uh
one of sort of poverty and deprivation
and vast swaths of arid red soil where
nothing but misery grows
and the second image is that of safaris
and there is so much more to the
continent to the region um and to our
own individual experiences you know the
way we build our communities where we
build our lives
54 countries 2 000 languages 1.4 billion
people um there's no one way of viewing
it you know like every other region in
the world it can be anything it is
everything it is stories of great joy
and triumph and success um and of course
there are stories of
great strut suffering and struggles as
we see in the uk throughout europe
throughout north america
um and so the idea of the book is to try
and fill in the blanks to try and give
people
a broader perspective more context as to
what's going on around the continent
these countries are artificial states
um
the colonial powers effectively you know
they met in 1884 at the berlin
conference
they set out some basic ground rules um
as to how they were going to conquer
africa and then they all set off
to do just that
they arrived on the continent
and they forced
10 percent of all ethnic groups to split
um they started drawing literally just
straight-line borders uh splitting
people and communities up and inventing
nations from nowhere
so the the realities that we're dealing
with now um
trying to build these nations trying to
get all these disparate ethnic groups to
come together and feel a common bond for
nations that did not exist before
the european uh colonialists turned up
is an ongoing challenge
and if you see it that way then you
realize that a lot of african countries
are doing incredibly well considering
the circumstances that they've dealt
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark answering your questions about the
war in ukraine and this from another
michael who
asks will we ever know for sure how many
russian soldiers have died during this
war whose numbers should we trust and
well the russians clearly have had
considerable casualties but they're not
in the business of letting us know on
what scale no they seem to admit
accidentally about 10 days ago that
about 10 000 uh soldiers had been killed
um and the
reliable estimates are now probably
around the 15 000 mark the ukrainians
say far more it's probably an
overestimate but conservative estimates
have got it down at seven or eight
thousand but i mean let's assume say
twelve to fifteen thousand and then the
number of casualties is normally three
times the number of dead because that's
just a dynamic of battle
and so it's it's likely that there are
about 15 000 russian dead and probably
45 000 in total casualties
and that's as many casualties as they
had in afghanistan over eight years and
they've achieved that in 46 days so
that's 60 000 out of action and the
initiative sorry for what 45 30 it might
have been three okay as many as
45 000 i mean given the invasion force
that they assembled it was about a
hundred and hundred thousand right okay
that's a considerable rate of address
and about 20 percent of that and the the
bbc have done some quite good uh work on
this by sampling the what they know of
the dead that about 20 of them seem to
be in the in the elite forces so their
airborne forces who are the best of the
best have suffered quite a lot again
it's not they're necessarily bad
soldiers but almost certainly bad
leadership and bad strategy so they've
suffered a lot within the forces that
they can afford to lose
okay another of our viewers is asking
this uh what does a lot of people
puzzling about it there's a there's an
example there what does the zed stand
for
in putin's russia and of course some
russia supporters putin's supporters
some using it now as as a symbol yeah
it's become the political demonstrations
yeah yeah it's become the it's yeah it's
become putin's symbol for this war but
what does it mean on the vehicles it's
almost certainly it's a designation of
which area these these uh vehicles are
in but particularly so that they can be
seen from the air because remember when
the russians invaded they realized what
must have realized that ukrainians
operate almost exactly the same systems
they've got the same old soviet systems
the same t-72 tanks the same
self-propelled artillery the same
armored personnel carriers so it's very
important to mark your own stuff in a
way that and you only mark it just
before you invade otherwise the other
side can see it and mark theirs in the
same way so they painted all the zeds
and the v's on them just a few days
before they were due to cross the border
and particularly you can see a lot of
them are visible from the air because
they certainly don't want their own air
force attacking them by mistaking the t7
so it's as simple as that it doesn't
mean anything more sinister because some
countries talking about outlawing it
along with the swastika well it's
because it's a zed it's taken on a
rather sort of spiky meaning but i mean
remember in d-day in 1944 that all the
allied uh equipment was painted with
stripes and they were the invasion
stripes so that anything with stripes on
was allied and that was important
okay well another question here uh
relates to the peace talks we don't hear
too much about them at the moment
between russia and ukraine and what it
would mean for the future of ukraine and
we've heard this from president
zielinski during the course of this war
what is neutral ukraine what does it
mean for ukraine in the long term
president zielenski's made it clear that
this issue of nato membership perhaps
not front and center anymore no it's
something to talk about
it would get it would buy him some time
to talk about neutrality and there are
different models i mean you know in
europe switzerland is is neutral austria
is neutral finland and sweden are
officially neutral until they join nato
fairly soon um so and the austrian state
treaty of 1955 was a treaty that the
soviets agreed to to they withdrew from
austria on condition that neutrality was
built into its constitution so that
provides a model it's something to talk
about and the future future ukraine
would certainly not be demilitarized
because it's it's going to be armed to
the teeth in the future because russia
under putin will always try to re-invade
that's the assumption you have to make
but it could be neutral in terms of its
formal relationships with military
alliances its relationship with nato
that's relatively easy to concede
actually but but for zolensky i think
neutrality is something to talk about
to show what a reasonable leader he is
against this
man in the kremlin who seems crazed by
the things he's saying and what about
the peace talks themselves as i say we
don't hear much about them at the moment
are
our contacts at least still continuing
yeah i mean they talk on a daily basis i
mean the teams are always talking to
each other and there are lots of teams
in in europe who are trying to keep all
the levels open so there's no lack of
there's no lack of contact at a very low
level but they won't talk until they
think they've got something to talk
about and what zelensky has said is look
i will talk when you get out of my
country and given that he's not losing
he's entitled to say that and the west
will back him
in whatever he says if he says i will
talk the west will say fine you talk and
we'll we'll back your judgment if you're
not prepared to talk because you're
you're going to keep on fighting to try
to throw them out of your country we'll
back that as well that's the view that
the west has taken okay we're getting
towards the end of this hour and uh
let's try and reach
some kind of
well conclusion or get towards
some idea of how this might all be
settled david is asking whether russia
was ever offered nato membership and
could they be offered this in the future
and what would it mean start with the
first part for us then michael was
russia ever offered nato membership
during that period of eastwood expansion
no um there was a time when they they
they themselves contemplated it george
robertson who of course was our defense
secretary in britain became the nato
secretary general and he records that in
the early 90s he went to see putin and
this was when um uh sorry the early
2000's putin become uh prime minister
under yeltsin then president after 99
with the background of the ruthless
citizen chechnya and putin said so i
suppose we could be in nato now then he
said all cosy and robertson said well um
you know we don't just take people in i
mean you could apply for membership and
we'd consider it and putin got very
upset and offended and he said you know
russia doesn't take its place in a queue
behind other countries you should want
us in and that was as far as the
conversation went and since then it's
gone out of the window what about this
uh very well presumably very far in the
future and it's got to be a post-putin
future i mean could russia be offered
nato membership it's very hard to
imagine at the moment i mean because
we're now in cold war too we can't get
away from that there's a fundamental
reality about this is a geopolitical
reality of europe and it is that
in europe europe can either be dominated
by germany
by russia or by america and all
europeans need to think about that and
ask themselves germany
russia or america so who would you
prefer
that's it that
that in your assessment so what has
europe has chosen at the moment well
germany and the united states some sort
of combination is basically you're not
you've been in the united states for a
long time but you know britain has never
dominated europe spain did at one time
france did at one time they'll never do
that again um italy did a very long time
ago or the renaissance states but just
think of europe in the period in of
course the last four or 500 years it is
dominated by one of the big powers and
the big powers since the beginning of
the 20th century have been russia
america and germany so it's one of those
three
they have to have predominant influence
and i say to my european friends so who
would you prefer
michael we are out of time thank you so
much geo philosophical question to
conjure with there
at the end thank you once again michael
clark there and you've been watching a
sky news tonight a special program uh on
ukraine coming up at eight the latest
reaction to the news that the prime
minister and the chancellor have been
fined for breaching covet rules
[Music]